[Music]
on today's show we talked to a young man
whose life feels stuck and he doesn't
know what to do we also talked to a
young father of three beautiful young
girls and he lost his previous spouse
and doesn't know how to tell them about
it we also talked to a mom whose son's
failing out of college and she doesn't
know what to do stay tuned
[Music]
hey what are you doing this is john with
the dr john delaney's show
man i hope you're doing well
hope the new year's going all right
hope you're staying out of trouble i
hope you're staying off the drugs
i don't even know i don't know what that
means but i don't know if you're staying
in school i was trying to think of some
back to school special language
stay in school don't do drugs that's the
new that's the new tagline for the show
james
stay in school don't do drugs does that
work you're the producer usually i come
up with a great idea and james tells me
in the meetings that's not a great idea
and he's right not true a hundred
percent of the time you write have i
ever had a great idea and you're like
i've never had a good idea i have so
many ideas and they're not great man
they're just not good kelly's ideas are
good james are good sarah's incredible
man you're being very self-deprecating
you have a lot of great ideas i think my
wife would disagree with you too all
right let's go to jason in chicago enjoy
tune what's up jason
what's up dude
hey nothing much uh i'm just a 20 year
old guy um i'm not being a little bit
trouble right now
uh i've been having like some physical
issues like uh back pain and
shoulder pain yeah working like a
physical job and
slightly nervous i guess about my future
because i'm this young and uh i'm
already having these issues
you're already having seizures
no we're like these issues uh issues
okay
so hey would you do me a huge favor
yeah okay we're going to pretend that
we're going to start this whole call
over and instead of being like i'm just
this like kind of 20 year old loser in
chicago i'm going to be like hey we're
going to go to jason in chicago then i
want you to say hey i'm jason i'm 20
years old
and
man i'm working hard i'm kind of nervous
about my future and then i want you to
choose to lift up your language a little
bit is that cool
yeah yeah sorry about that no don't be
sorry it's all good we're just all we're
learning we're practicing ready
all right let's go to jason in chicago
what's up jason how are we doing
hey we're doing pretty good uh i'm a 20
year old guy
and i'm not being looking [ __ ] uh
it's working pretty hard uh fiscal labor
what do you do what kind of physical
labor do you do uh warehouse
warehouse just don't sell embossing
packet package handling there you go
okay throwing boxes yeah man that's
that's hard how long you been doing that
uh year and a half okay
so uh how can i help man
i don't know
um
it just it's been kind of raining on me
i'm just having like a little bit of
issues with my physical health i guess
okay like back problems and shoulder
at this this type of age and it's kind
of
it's uh
i'm a bit afraid of my future honestly
what do you want to do with your future
uh
not sure i've been um
actually i bought some tools and uh i've
looked into like cell phone repair okay
so when you when when i ask you like man
if if you could see it all come together
and if i could just if i could just snap
my fingers and make all my dreams come
true
i want to prepare cell phones
is that right
maybe
if that's it man i'm all i stand behind
you
is that it
what do you want to do that might be it
that might be it
uh honestly i'm not i'm not too sure
to be honest
where does where does that self-limiting
belief come from
i guess uh i don't have much experience
in the world
why not right now 20 years old you've
been you've been living you still live
at home now you've been living at home
yeah i've been living on them okay
do you live
out of your house now
uh no i just i still live with my with
my mom okay
so
[Music]
i'm a bit nervous sorry no it's okay i'm
nervous too i'm not very good at this
you're way better at this than i am
um okay let me let me let me back out a
little bit
what do you want from your life
don't overthink it just just rattle them
off what do you want for your life you
want to get married
maybe if i find the one okay there's not
a one you're gonna have to choose to
marry somebody that the myth of the one
isn't real do you wanna have kids
someday or no
love yeah i'd want some kids
okay i've got a couple it's awesome it's
also exhausting and expensive and it's
the best
um do you want to live with your mom
forever have your own place
no yeah i have my own place definitely
you want to live in the south and the
north east and the west where do you
want to live
um
that i don't know i mean the snow is you
know kind of hard
there's no sales tax in tennessee i mean
their sales tax is no income tax yeah
there's for sure sales tax
um
so
here's the thing
it feels like you're trapped man you've
trapped yourself by an inability to
imagine anything other than this
immediate moment is that fair yeah
definitely
do you struggle with any sort of mental
health issues
you ever been diagnosed with depression
not that i know of not that you know
okay how'd you do in school
um
not that well but i've i've been going
to community college and
i've done kind of good and then i
started
like
not having the discipline to do well why
do you choose to not have discipline
i
just i kind of feel direction
you kind of feel directionless
yeah
just i'm not sure where to go
like i'd want to go somewhere but i'm
not sure where
like as a career and
you said job-wise not sure
but that's different than discipline why
do you choose to not have discipline
um
i guess just i get being lost
career-wise but every day you can choose
to wake up at 5 30 in the morning and
get some exercise in and to eat well and
to do a little bit of service and to do
a gratitude journal
and to get your homework and assignments
done and study for that day's quiz or
exam you can make that choice every day
and
but you don't you choose not to do those
things why do you choose not to do those
things
uh
because um
not too sure uh
how'd you find this show
oh i've been watching youtube
okay um i've i've watched ramsay and
then i've saw
uh dr dalone's show dr john colony
charlemagne yeah that's me a couple
episodes yep yeah how um
how much youtube do you watch
oh that yeah that'd be a problem
[Laughter]
okay so here's here's what i want you to
do
okay
um you feel stuck
and
i get that
there are
millions of people watching this right
now who are stuck
and they don't know where to go they
don't know what's up what's down
really crazy it's just bonkers when you
look across the media landscape right
now you know what is absolutely getting
crushed in the media landscape
is um
any sort of
like books or
you know
courses to correct to help to change
your life
and i think people are absolutely stone
exhausted
i think 2020 they all ran out and went
yeah let's get them and then 2021 they
just said whatever dude
oh cool new variant cool whatever
and i think there's been so much loss so
much chaos so much misinformation so
much ups and downs and sideways that
people are just cached
here's the good news
that means if you will get up and be
disciplined about a few things you will
go so far so fast
that means if you will care about jason
just a little bit
it will mag that care you invest in
yourself will magnify and for anybody
listening if you feel stuck and trapped
and you want to make just a tiny little
step towards a new direction
everything can change
and so here's what i can't do jason we
could talk for five hours on what do you
want to do with your life where you want
to go what do you want to be when you
grow up all those things
um
here's what i'm going to do i'm going to
give you some stuff okay
okay but i'm gonna give it to you but
you gotta promise you'll use it do you
promise
i promise all right here's five things
i'm gonna roll out i'm gonna fi i'm
gonna ask five things of you i'm gonna
give you some stuff cool awesome number
one are you currently enrolled in
community college
oh yeah yeah okay that means you pay for
the counseling services
yep i want you to make an appointment
today
all right shoot an email to him and say
i'd like to schedule an appointment say
i am lost
directionless and i need some help
okay
i want you to use those words i want you
to go sit with a professional and set up
over a couple of sessions and walk
alongside them you're already paying for
the service you might as well use it
okay
number two i'm gonna send you a copy of
my friend ken coleman's new book from
paycheck to purpose so stay on the line
and kelly's gonna get your information
we'll mail that out to you and i'm gonna
send you a cop uh free one of his
assessments i love giving away ken's
stuff it's so great it doesn't affect my
bottom line at all it's so good um but
ken's assessment and it's it's a guide
you work through to say like what am i
gonna be what am i gonna what do i wanna
do with my life
okay
yeah the fourth thing
i want you to get on amazon today
you love the internet and i want you to
order the book jocko olynyk's book
discipline equals freedom
okay
it'll cost you like 10 bucks
yeah is that cool
yeah and then here's number five
i want you to write a letter
to jason in five years
and in that letter i want you just to
describe exactly where you are
where are you living
are you married do you have kids what
are you doing why are you doing it
i want you to be very very specific
about where you're headed
and that letter is going to be great
discussion material for you and your
counselor there at the college
and from that letter i want you to pull
out some of those things and make bullet
points and hang them up on your wall so
you can look at them every day
and in jocko's book you're going to work
through a workout program and a daily
routine
and a set of practices that you're
that you're going to be committed to
you're going to read ken's book and
you're gonna do some direction like yeah
i think that sounds like fun man i think
that i would love doing that for a
career and you're gonna walk through his
plan on how to get get clear and get the
job that you want how to stay in that
job
but all of this starts with an idea that
i'm no longer gonna be directionless i'm
gonna choose to not be directionless i'm
not just gonna sit here in this island
and go nowhere i'm just gonna start
going somewhere
and along the way i'm gonna pick up the
wisdom of some smart people who've been
down that road before
i don't feel scared you know it feels
lost
big thing get off the internets bro
let's turn them off just turn them off
and i know i make my living on the
internets but you need to turn them off
turn them off and go be with people go
outside be with people go exercise go
for a walk go serve your neighborhood go
get a trash sack and just start picking
up trash in your neighborhood listen to
the podcast and quit watching on youtube
just get outside and get some fresh air
go do something great for your community
okay
be the guy that's always picking up go
do something get off the internets
brother
we love you hey after you get these five
things done i want you to holler back at
us we're gonna walk alongside you and
see what's next all right we'll be right
back on the dr john delaney show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john deloney show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six six-month waiting list
or i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody and it's way
across town what do i do cause i want
help with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i wanna be a better mom i gotta process
this trauma that happened to me when i
was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john dolone show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back let's go to chris
in pennsylvania what's up chris
hey how you doing remarkable how about
you
i'm doing all right
what's up dude i can help
yeah so i have a question for you uh
my wife and i we both have lost our
previous spouses
wow
how old are you
i am 38
and my wife is 35. oh my gosh man i'm so
sorry to hear that for both of you
thanks man how long how long ago for
both of you
uh
hers was
she lost him about eight years ago
and one is going to be eight years here
in january okay
all right wow okay uh we have three kids
three girls
um i'm a
girl dad
me too man but only one
yeah and what we were talking about the
other day and we're both huge fans of
you and we wanted to know
is when and how do we bring up our
previous
history with our daughters
um so they all have any idea
no how old are they
the oldest is four and a half okay then
we have two two and a half
and then six weeks
oh gosh
you know can i say
when did y'all just like have this when
did this come up
when did you think like when did you all
have the conversation you and your wife
like we're gonna have to tell our
daughters at some point
uh we've talked about in the past but
last week we were driving somewhere and
i think i was telling her about a show i
just listened to one of your shows and
i'm like hey we should probably think
about this
and another another aspect to this is we
actually last june had a miscarriage at
six weeks
and we also
have not brought that up so that's also
in the mix of kind of bringing up all
this
into the msa
yeah you've got a lot
so
um man
broadly speaking
your kids
will not
and i mean i wish there was a nicer way
to say this okay so just take my blunt
language here with the grain of salt
um or take it with grace because i wish
there was a more graceful way to say
this
your kids will not have the baggage of
your past that you do
right their story will simply be
the story of their world which is both
of their parents were married to other
people who passed away
and so
normally
i especially with a four and a half two
and a half it's one of those things that
if it comes up in natural conversation
well and here's a good example my
daughter's five she has been really
curious about like tell me another story
about when i was a baby or let's look at
pictures of me as a baby she wants to
know some of that history and she's five
or six that's about when i i think the
curiosity will start
um when did you and daddy meet when was
he your boyfriend when was she your
girlfriend um
and kids don't have
quite the same not quite they don't have
nearly the same perception of time
and so
forever started when they
had consciousness consciousness does
that make sense so the idea that there
was a before them is weird and then when
they realized there was a before them
then there was a before y'all two were
together
and then there was above like what you
used to date other people so the whole
thing is just like that their world
expands like an accordion as you all
have these conversations and so what i
don't want you guys to do is feel
pressure that we have to have this big
grandiose conversation with them
and because they've got to know about
their past and their parents past they
got to know it and then all sudden you
use your needs
as use them as a proxy to get your needs
met which is i don't want to have these
secrets in our in my house
versus
when they come up then you have these
conversations
i will say that having some sort of
context for death is is good
whether that's a goldfish a grandparent
a pet
one of the most yeah we go ahead we had
a nate we had a neighbor uh
six months ago he passed away from covid
so i think she kind of gets an idea but
it's still
hard to gauge and whether she truly
understands like what death is so this
is a great great opportunity
to
you and your wife separately together
get with your daughter and say hey we
just want you to know that we've been
really sad that tim mr tim down the
street died
and your kid may your daughter may ask
well what's died
or he'll come back
or whatever that looks like
and
you can you let the her know
here's what grief looks like in a in a
way my friend rachel cruz says share
don't don't scare
in a way that she goes oh my parents
experience sad too
because then it humanizes grief
humanizes y'all it makes your daughter
one day when she feels grief she won't
feel crazy because she's got a picture
of it because she saw you guys grief
and then you'll always have this anchor
point of death
so that when it comes up
where uh you and daddy
you know
uh when y'all
first got married or what however the
conversation goes right i'm trying to
pretend i'm a four and a half year old
and i'm there psychologically but not
you know what i mean um
it will come up and that's when your
wife or you whoever gets this question
in in a non-dramatic way but in a
factual this is just our life this is i
got blonde hair i was at one time
married to somebody else and they died
remember like mr tim
my previous wife died and here's where
that can get scary for a kid you mean
mommy could die yeah she could
she probably won't
and every day we tell mommy we love her
she probably won't
but yeah we all die someday
and that's when the you get the
existential crisis between four to seven
years old and they start to realize oh
there was a before time oh there's gonna
be an after me too and it's you know you
may remember that from your childhood
and um
so
it's just a part of their story
the greatest gift you can give your kids
though is to let them know that you're a
person and you get sad sometimes
it may be eight years is eight years do
you still have like a
i don't know on your on your first
wife's birthday do you you know do you
go have a drink or do you go out with
buddy i mean do you still
have seasons of sadness
uh yeah there's still definitely still
seasons especially
i would say the biggest ones around the
time whenever everything happened which
is you know coming up in a couple weeks
so yeah it was great so that might be
four and a half depending on your kid
feels a little bit early
um five and a half might not be
depending again
my if my daughter if my wife and i had
the situation it wouldn't be too early
for my daughter but also granted i'm
kind of a weird dad and so we talk about
death a lot in my house and so
um her therapy bills and my sons are
going to be different later on down the
road
in some families it might not be
appropriate till 7 or 8.
or the poor family the other day that
shot one is a buddy of mine and his
daughter got a hold of the questions for
humans cards i have and found out santa
claus wasn't real and she's nine or ten
she found out from me right so
that might oh hey oh yeah it's awesome
so that might not be it you're gonna
have to know your kid
but it might be
hey daddy's really sad today and i have
a story i have never told you but i have
a story i was married before mommy
i had a another wife
and she
was in a car wreck she got sick whatever
the story is and again you're talking a
30 thousand foot story because she's
five or six
um
but
she passed away and like like mr tim she
died and
just once a year daddy gets really sad
and um when i get sad i like to be
around people that i love and i like to
write letters i like to hug and
sometimes i even cry
and
it's that level of honesty and
vulnerability that is gonna i mean
you're talking legacy changing stuff
brother
like you're giving your daughters tools
that she will use for the rest of her
life
and she will ask hard questions and it's
it she will take your cue her her cue
from you and your wife as to
are my parents trustworthy can i ask
them hard questions are they safe to go
to when i'm scared or nervous
based on how you all answer those
questions you know what i mean
yep yeah
um i'm sorry that that's been your road
so far and i'm also really grateful that
y'all found each other and looks like
you all have created a beautiful life
yeah
it's yeah it's all part of god's plan
it's surreal though right like when you
sit down and look at the look at it
oh it really is do you ever have those
weird moments
yeah yeah can i can i can i
ask you one can i dig in for a second
sure i've had a couple of buddies in my
life whose spouse has passed away they
got remarried
and then they had kids
and the inevitable you know
to drink question is like
oh my gosh
the greatest things in my life are my
kids they wouldn't be here if the worst
thing my life hadn't happened you know
what i mean you get these weird
existential loops have you all have you
all had those conversations together
uh yeah we have
kind of yeah
my wife brings out my wife brings that
up a lot she's
not helpful
so she'll just come over you know she'll
be sad and just be like
excited and happy because she's like you
know
there was a point in my life where kids
are never in my future and then and now
look at us now we have these what the
time we haven't really talked about in
the last six weeks but we had this two
beautiful girls that are just amazing
and now we have three and pretty sure
our family is complete now uh
but fingers crossed it's quite a story
yeah
so
here's what i would um
want to encourage you with
never keep secrets from each other
and right
um
you can choose to not tell not to go
down those loop looping spirals
we've become obsessed in our culture
with the scientific meth like the
the asking hard questions and let's
follow the plan until we get to the
answer let's and the other thing we are
obsessed with is taking everything apart
at it to its smallest piece if we can
understand what makes up the atom then
we can understand what makes up humanity
and we can understand it makes up the
cause like we've that's that's our
current ethos
and so sometimes we want to know why why
did this happen and back it out here and
we can make ourselves crazy on these
reverse engineering explorations of our
life
right
and man what a gift just to say i don't
know
but look at these three beautiful girls
now
you know what i mean
and our pain is a part of our story and
so is our joy
um
you're a gift my man i hope that helps
um
ultimately
this is a bad analogy have you all had
the sex talk yet at all with your
daughters
no no
by the way i'm looking forward to that
day either
[Laughter]
it'll come sooner than it'll come in the
most random you'll be in a target and
it'll be like oh
oh we're talking about tampons all right
i'm in i'm in and you're gonna be ready
to rock and roll right um that happens
um but in a similar way
if we can have those conversations with
our daughters and with our sons and not
let them feel one iota of weirdness or
shame about their bodies
then they don't have weirdness and shame
about their bodies and if we don't have
weirdness and shame about our bodies
they don't they don't learn weirdness
and shame
similarly
if we
are
bold enough and courageous enough and
honest enough to understa like to speak
out death is part of this it's built
into the system here
we've made it this evil hush hush don't
talk about a thing and it's a part of
all of us
it's all of us right it's just the
operating instructions right
yeah how do we get into the miscarriage
side of things because i feel like
that's a slightly different discussion
with the whole
you know there was a baby in mommy's
body and there wasn't and
just we weren't really sure how the
like we don't want to hold it from
them but we just don't know the best way
to approach that
yeah i i again if if
if this was a week six
uh miscarriage and the kids didn't know
do they know that mommy was pregnant
no we hadn't told them yet okay that
might be something i'd hang on to and
because because again they're four and
two and
yeah babbling right
uh i'd probably hang on to that um
and if
either of you have a season of grief
around that around that passing right
around that miscarriage then you let
your kids know that mommy's really sad
mommy's really sad
um daddy's really sad
and then over time that conversation
you'll have that conversation with your
daughters
and it would be
um
we've experienced multiple miscarriages
i got the names of
our
babies tattooed on my body and those are
conversations i've had with both of my
kids
but again they're a little bit older and
we talk we have a context of that type
of discussion in our house
and that's not for everybody at age five
or six or seven um but those
conversations will come
again that's setting up a
i'm willing to be vulnerable and tell
you about my life
not about you've got to know all the
things going on behind closed doors with
me and mom
you know what i mean
yep
did i remember hearing you say in a
previous episode there was about three
weeks before having this latest baby my
wife was just very
overwhelmed with emotions and
like she's grieving you know losing that
one baby but now we're having this one i
could have swear i heard you say
something that's a natural body response
so
was i correct in that because that's why
i told her and she really was glad that
i had heard that from you but we just
wanted to kind of get clarification on
that about grief being a natural body
response
yeah it's like
like we were excited because the baby
was coming but she was extremely sad
because you know we had lost the other
baby
well you i mean
so you went through a terrible thing you
have this
grief
and then you get pregnant again
and that grief was devastating to your
body physically psychologically
spiritually your body felt that it
experienced it all of the stress
hormones and the lack of sleep and the
lack of nutrition and the lack of
intimacy all those things the isolation
so it puts a pin in that to use a
terrible like google earth uh
analogy here
and then it remembers and the next time
she gets pregnant it sounds the alarms
hey remember last time look out look out
look out
of that
yep and so what you have to do is to
recognize in a graceful curious way dude
my body's just trying to love me
and once your body recognizes oh no i
i'm i'm in control
i appreciate it and i remember that too
and it was hard and it was terrible
that's why you hear me say it all the
time about writing letters what letters
caused us to do is to pause for an hour
or 30 minutes
and to think clearly write things down
look for evidence demand evidence to
these things
and to then
process and the whole time you're
breathing and you're slowing down and
you're being intentional and what you're
doing is you're telling your amygdala
hey we're still in control up here
we're good you don't need to run off and
set off every alarm we have set off the
anxiety alarms or the depression alarms
or whatever's going on
and then we can move on to the next
doesn't mean we're not sad doesn't mean
we're not
joy joyful about the new baby and sad
about the the baby that we lost we're
not it's not it's both in same time all
that's the same time
and there's no right or wrong way to do
it but yeah it's just most people fight
their bodies they want to shut off that
sadness and the sucky part is joy and
sadness they're on the same
they're on the same switch man
okay does that make you what i'm saying
so
feel them both they're both right
it's when one takes over
that you say maybe we need to go talk to
somebody when i just can't acknowledge
the joy of this new baby because i can't
get
the baby that we lost out of my head i
keep seeing the i keep reliving that
experience i keep reliving the
miscarriage i keep reliving the cramps i
keep reliving the headaches and the
crying it's when you can't stop and it
loops and your body gets stuck in that
loop loop loop that's when you go see a
professional but the okay
i hate this i'm weeping and at the same
time i'm holding this baby and laughing
and that's part of that's part of the
journey
okay
can i tell you this thank you
yeah those three girls are
one of the dead lottery when they got
you
well thank you like for real but
but my wife says too
she's lying to you she's supposed to say
that
i'm a podcast host i know i'm just
kidding your wife's a genius she's knows
way more than my
idiot butt does whatever that's awesome
dude yeah you got a lot there man y'all
got a history of grief grief is a part
of your story
and so over time as your daughters dig
in and ask questions and ask to be
invited into your story
talk to them
share don't scare
but let them know yeah
death is a part of our life same with
the dogs and with the goldfish same with
their neighbor down the street mr tim
same with all of us
it's hard sheltering our kids from that
type of reality does nobody any good
we'll be right back on the dr john lung
show
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert and a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200.
trust me that's triple eight loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement mls id 1591
nmls consumer access dot org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane sweet
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back let's go to mary
in casey missouri what's up mary what's
up
hey dr john how are you today i'm good i
like you
i'm wonderful i'm so
just honored to be speaking with you so
i reached out um
we have a son so i i re i'm divorced and
remarried we have a blended family and
our middle child who's my oldest is 18
and he's a freshman in college
we are in baby step 7 and so
we
you know he really wanted to go away to
school
he struggled his senior year of high
school
and so with grades and that kind of
thing you struggle academically
psychologically yes
academically
started to do some poor you know made
some poor choices with drinking and
vaping and that kind of thing
my husband and i had a lot of talks with
him about you know this is a fresh start
we believe in you and he really wanted
to go away so he did so he's he's down
in the ark at university of arkansas
okay and uh really really really
struggled um
classes uh
just
like he's very social right so he's high
social didn't get into a fraternity made
a lot of friends
and the social life just took over and
so here we are at the end of the
semester he's on his way home right now
and um has all f's
so
um he has a life coach and he's worked
with her for about a year now and we've
all believed in him and we really really
want to see him succeed
um
he has he really really wants to go back
but it's expensive right and i i i just
got a loss as to what to do i want to
his his dad told him he would not pay
for uh last semester so that's when my
husband and i did so now it's his dad's
turn to
pay
and
it's just really hard because he's
failed and yet
right he's only 18 and i believe in him
and i i'm just so confused as to as to
what to do and i'm concerned about him
he's admitted that he's drinking a lot
um i know that he vapes quite a bit he
says all of his friends are raping
um so i'm concerned about his health i'm
concerned about his future
and just kind of lost so i reached out
to you because i think the world of you
well i appreciate that and i've i've had
this conversation i can't even tell you
probably a thousand times in my career
with
with people in your exact situation so
um
here's what i'll tell you
um the greatest gift you could give your
18 year old son right now
is to feel the weight of the
consequences of his actions
and that will be hard on you
it will feel like a betrayal to him
but he's 18 year old man
now
as much as he's a kid he's a child and
you're gonna hear me tell other people
that you're eight they're 18 year olds
or children and i will i'm telling you
yours is a is an adult
um
you're playing a long game with him now
you're playing a what does a 30 year old
son look like and we're gonna reverse
engineer that
and so right now it feels like the whole
world
it feels like everything's crashing down
you feel like a failure because your kid
failed and what did we do and could it
be this and is it the divorce all those
things
you can get existential about it and
that's fine and all good the reality is
he went to college he decided to drink
and party and hang out and he flunked
out
he's going to be on academic probation
if it's my son my son's coming home and
he's going to get a job and he's going
to go to community college and prove to
me that he wants to be in school and
the way the language i use in my house
is all about choice
so if one of my um
my son i hate when parents weaponize uh
interactions with kids meaning
oh you didn't get your thing done well
you're not coming fishing with me
i don't like that but here's what i do
the same the consequence is the same but
the semantics means everything
i will sit down with my son and say i
did this recently
if x and y and z does not happen
that is you choosing to not come spend
time with me at this on this trip
and i will choose to be heartbroken
because this trip is no fun without you
i don't like hunting or fishing alone
without my son
and if you choose to
go to bed early or hang out and not get
your stuff done
i will be sad that that was your choice
and in the same
and so i'm i'm i'm not weaponizing my
relationship i'm letting him know that
the weight of this interaction is on his
shoulders he's got some choices to make
and i would sit down with your son and
have that same conversation
i want you to go to college i want you
to go to university arkansas where
you're where it's a great school and
it's great this and career and blah blah
great
so far you have chosen to drink and to
party and to fail
that's the choice you made and i i'm
choosing to be heartbroken about that
because i know you're smarter than that
and i know you're more capable of that
but these are choices you made if you
choose to get all a's at community
college then i will choose to
reinvest in your education but at this
point the choices you've made suggest
that you don't even want to be in
college
see how that that i want him to feel the
weight of the decisions and the choices
he made of course he wants to go back of
course all of his friends are there of
course all the girl of his dreams is
there of course all of the
but the choices you made i want a
million dollars too but if i spend all
my money every day then i'm choosing to
not have a million dollars
right
so the greatest gift you could give him
is to let him know that there are
consequences to his choices
and to what and to love him the whole
way through by the way
love them the whole way through some
parents have to gear themselves up for
this conversation it ends up being a so
yeah so you gotta i wouldn't do that let
them know that you're heartbroken too
it's so
thank you this is really good couple
different scenarios he's meeting with
his dad tomorrow and he's asking dad i
want to go back please believe in me
he's written him a letter et cetera et
cetera they don't have a very good
relationship
if dad chooses to fund
the next semester which is completely
out of my control yep
then what
then here's what's going to happen
he's going to go back and he's going to
flunk out and they're not going to let
him go to college there ever again
and so the number of times i counseled
students and their parents away from the
college where i was getting money for
their enrollment
so that they didn't put themselves in a
position where they could never go again
and by the way if you flunk out you've
got to report that on every application
to another college you ever try to make
and so whatever life coach y'all have by
the way sounds like they're terrible
i i just if i'm paying for a year of a
life coach and my kid drinks his way
through freshman year i'm not going to
pay that life coach ever again
right yeah like i don't know that life's
life coach r us program on the internet
i don't know
um
but i
like i would never let my kid go back
without a game plan without really
strict accountability who's gonna walk
alongside you who's gonna and by the way
i'm a grown-up i don't have time to
babysit my 18 year olds like i want to
see all your assignments and dude you're
in college
right that's the thing
well do we have weekly you know my
wonderful husband has said he can report
to me every friday at five or whatever
what his grades are i'm like this just
doesn't i don't know i it doesn't feel
like he's 18. you know and at the
university of arkansas i guarantee you
they've got a counseling center and a
tutoring center and a academic support
center and
faculty tutors and gas that help the
faculty tutors the chances to be you
have to decide i don't want to be
successful
at the university of arkansas for you to
flunk out it has to be a choice you make
and if you've got uh
learning disabilities or learning
exceptionalities they've got ada office
and the 504 8504 stuff they've got all
kinds of
organizations and groups and
the resources are endless
and your son made a choice to flunk out
of college
or flunk the semester
and so the the most loving thing i think
anybody does is doesn't set him up self
up in a position to you don't buy your
16 year old a ferrari
because they don't need that i'm
protecting you from the from your bad
decision
i want you if you're going to hit the
gas i want you to hit honda accord gas
not
ferrari gas right i want you to make an
80 mile an hour wreck not a 280 mile an
hour wreck
well right and i mean he had his he had
his car we had to take his car away he
was driving too fast we warned him and
warned him we got rid of his car
and similarly reckless
yes yes yes and so i don't want him to
be put in a situation where
he's gonna have his 18 year old plans i
really really want this and hey i
believe he really wants it i believe he
got embarrassed i believe he's ashamed i
believe it was a wake-up call i get it
i think there's an old bobby knight
little basketball coach who said
everybody
wants to be a champion everybody on the
court wants to win that game
but the game's not won on that court the
game is won the year before in the
weight room and in the practice room and
in the film room
right and so your son really wants this
but he doesn't have a plan he doesn't
have the acumen he doesn't have a
success strategy he doesn't have any
he's had two years now or a year and a
half of
of
substandard academic success he needs to
get a couple of wins under his belt get
that at a local community college either
for free if if arkansas has that program
i don't know what state you're in oh
you're you're in kansas missouri uh if
they've got the uh if they've got a free
community college program or it's gonna
be like 50 bucks an hour or whatever go
do that
right
but set him up in a position to get some
little wins so that he can choose to
make bigger win decisions
and this is one of those i don't know
what your relationship is with your
ex-husband but i'd call him and say i'm
i know i can't have i don't have any say
into what next semester looks like
i believe the best thing for our son is
that he feel the weight of his
consequences and that he spends a
semester at a community college let him
show us this is what he wants i i know
that it could be pie in the sky
depending on what kind of partnership
you have with your ex
but i would probably make that phone
call
let him know you love him
you're your son and let him know he's
got to feel the weight of the
consequences of his choices
thank you so much for the call mary
great great question great question all
right as we wrap up today's show oh
the beatles huh
just kidding smashing pumpkins just
kidding
kelly's favorite song of all time
i don't even this is like in the late
1800s this record came out when did this
album come out do you even remember
was it 92 88 oh i believe it was 89. 89.
oh my gosh did they have electricity in
89
just kidding i was alive then too
it's off the appetite for destruction
record
the song is called paradise city look at
the smile on kelly's face it's ear to
ear just makes her happy
and it goes like this
just an urchin living under the street
i'm a hard case that's tough to beat i'm
your charity case so buy me something to
eat i'll pay it another time take it to
the end of the line
rags and riches are so they say you
gotta keep pushing for the fortune and
fame i've always thought it was keep
pushing for the punch in the face till
just now
keep pushing for the fortune and fame
you know it's all a gamble when it's
just a game you treat it like a capital
crime
everybody's doing the time
so
take me down to the paradise city where
the grass is green and the girls are
pretty
and smart and brilliant i hear you
internets
oh won't you please take me home
take me down to the paradise city where
the grass is green and james is kind
i wonder what that would be like
oh won't you please take me home
we're taking everybody home right here
on the doctor john dolone's show see you
soon
you